my channel is sponsored by samsung so we
will hear more from them in a couple of
minutes hello everyone welcome to
another episode of good gaming news
which is a weekly series where i talk
about video game news that i feel
positively about that i think is good
because there is enough negativity on
the internet related this video is
sponsored but i usually get to pick what
sponsorship goes in what video like they
don't get to pick that i get to pick
that and because i felt so positively
about this particular sponsorship i
decided to put it in this video but
we'll get to that couple of stories this
week and the first one is just one that
it's not a huge story uh it's not not
anything that's gonna blow anyone's
pants off
just by the lack of substance but it is
something that i feel very positively
about especially
because it never needed to happen the
headline is thus this is from
tweaktown.com valve has a lot of games
in development dev's ramping up projects
valve is still very much making video
games and currently has a lot of games
in development and a good portion of its
employees are working on them you would
hope before we even get into the story
the reason that i say that this is good
news and that i feel positively about it
um is because
yeah valve does not need to make video
games really ever again or at least it's
been that way for a long time steam is a
money printing machine they just sit
there and hundreds of games get put on
that platform every month probably even
thousands at this point there are so
many video games and every sale steam
gets 30 percent
of profit from that um which is you know
the industry standard epic are one of
the very few that actually give devs a
higher cut which is a very good thing
about the epic game store despite a lot
of people not liking it for an abundance
of reasons they do give devs more money
valve
the publishers they're all taken 30 and
the monopoly that steam's had has lasted
just such a long time that people have
been buying almost every aaa game on
steam
i kind of hope that this came as a
result of uh more publishers having
their own stores
of the competition with something like
the epic game store i don't know i hope
so but basically they really didn't need
to make games
and that sucks because the games they
make are very good they also function
very differently from anyone else in the
industry i have friends who work there
and everyone i know who works there
loves it there they have this like
anti-leadership kind of thing i don't
know how they describe it but it's along
the lines of like they try not to have
actual t instruction management
positions and instead kind of try to let
leaders
find themselves which sounds kind of
nice i've said this before a big gripe i
have with the games industry and i think
a lot of new industries like tech in
general uh people just keep getting
promoted even though they have no
management experience and then they end
up managing people and making people
miserable
or asserting ego or just like liking
being a manager so they have control
over people and it's nasty very very
dumb thing the industry keeps doing okay
sorry more of the story this is from
derek stickland valve recently confirmed
a new steam deck is in development and
that the system is multi-generational
hardware but it's not giving up on games
anytime soon either also if you haven't
played half-life alex
i understand that you need hardware for
it but if you have that hardware and you
haven't played it
i genuinely think it's one of the best
games ever made
i'm pretty confident in saying that
it'd go in my like top 50 somewhere
it's very good okay to get to the meat
of this in a recent interview with
famitsu valves greg kumar
that's unfortunate confirms that more
half-life games are on the way and that
the new mystery titles are currently in
the works behind valve steamy corridors
we're not stopping making games at all
valve has a lot of games and development
we will continue to release games
game development is very important to
valve i don't know the exact numbers but
the percentage of employees involved in
game development is high a lot of people
are involved they're in a really
interesting position where everyone
wants half-life 3 but there's no way
that half-life 3 could really ever live
up to half-life 2
or half-life 1.
and i think probably the most reasonable
route is for them to go like you can't
be groundbreaking again like half-life
was which is the same as saying doom
wasn't groundbreaking again when it came
to doom 2016 or do maternal but what
they did was like really focus on the
thing that doom did well and why people
love doom though i guess i personally
love doom for the puzzly aspects and
those two new games don't have as much
of that
point is half-life's a really tough one
um i feel like they have to just really
focus on what people like about those
first two games and expand on them where
they can and i do feel like alex did
that but they had the benefit of
avoiding being called half-life three i
just feel like a firefly three comes out
it's a mess
it's gonna be really hard to do but uh
yes they did say there's more about the
half-life world alex's assignment valve
has more to say about the world cool
also says he would like to make another
portal someday and that the world
deserves further exploration i am
inclined to agree so of course i'm i'm
pretty sure that they're still working
on in the valley of gods which is an
interesting one right so this is campo
santo before campo santo was bought by
valve so um for if you don't know the
creators of firewatch everyone was very
excited about what they'd be working on
after firewatch
and they announced in the valley of gods
at a game awards and then got purchased
by steam but like it wasn't a normal
acquisition it was like they just folded
into steam they got off it and just
folded it and the last conversation that
i remember uh having was somebody who
was involved in that
they told me that they all opted to work
on half-life because that's what they
really wanted to do and were
appreciative of steam for letting them
do that but that they were still able to
work on in the valley of gods once
half-life was done um i remember a lot
of stories coming out around that period
of time where everyone's very upset
about in the valley of gods being
cancelled but again when i spoke to
people who were first-hand sources who
were involved in that it seemed like
that wasn't the case it's like they they
got a quiet and they chose to work on
half-life because they were so excited
about the project
but they they can still work on in the
valley of gods
it seems to me like if this is a game
that still exists and is still being
made in some capacity at valve which
isn't off the table it wasn't like it
was cancelled i mean it still says tbd
here right like it still still has a
steam page then we'd probably hear about
that at the game awards too unless i
missed some news that it was canceled
but i don't i don't think that actually
happened i feel like it was misreported
at the time in any case glad to have
valve come out in an interview you know
that's official press that means it's
probably sooner rather than later
otherwise they would just say we're not
talking about that right now they
clearly knew it would drive traffic
means it's happening it is time to talk
about the samsung odyssey arc which i
got to see at pax west most of you
probably already know that i'm running a
super ultra wide monitor and i love it i
speak positively about it all the time i
would never go back the only thing i
would do is go bigger the samsung
odyssey arc
is so big i
was in disbelief for those of you who
don't know the samsung odyssey r is
beautiful first and foremost but it's a
55 inch and 1000 r curved screen 165
hertz and one millisecond gtg it has a
cockpit mode and eclipse lighting it has
its own sound dome which is crazy cool
the thing that i was most excited about
though is the multi-view comes with a
separate little control panel that
allows you to split the screen in
various different forms my current
monitor only allows for two splits or
three splits but you can't customize
where each screen sits or the different
sizes of the screens in fact i end up
getting like these black bars on one
side or the other um it's annoying the
samsung odyssey arc
allows you to have a bunch of screens
put them wherever you want and resize
them the idea of being able to do this
to have one picture or frame to monitor
obs and then one to monitor
my playstation and then one to monitor
twitch chat while streaming or creating
content oh it's so cool to throw some
more specs at you it also has hdr 10
plus neural quantum processor the arc
dial of course amd freesync premium pro
flex move quantum matrix technology
matte display and a game bar alongside
the gaming hub yeah i was just blown
away by this so when they asked if i
would want to talk about it i was like
absolutely yes
i loved it you can pre-order now at
samsung.com amazon.com or bestbuy.com
and get a 200 gift card for future
purchases these offers are only good
through september 11th so be sure to
take advantage of these offers while
they last of course terms and conditions
apply second we have crystal dynamics
taste control of its most beloved games
this is a really really small one like
this is the whole page on the crystal
dynamics website but
i'm really glad to hear this news so it
says we're excited to inform you that
crystal dynamics has taken control of
several game franchises including tomb
raider and legacy of kane from the
game's previous owner square enix
limited as a result of this change
crystal dynamics or its affiliate is now
the owner of these games and the
controller of the gameplay and personal
data related to them if you'd like to
know more please refer to our new terms
of service and privacy notice we look
forward to taking this new and exciting
journey with you which is such a weird
process right that they made tomb raider
of legacy of kane but they were owned by
square enix and they've now been bought
by effectively enforcer group who then
bought crystal dynamics who then gave
those properties back to crystal
dynamics i said this on the last episode
of this show that i don't generally love
mass acquisitions
i feel like they're ultimately not great
um for gamers if there isn't a lot of
competition and i feel like we have
healthy competition right now but that
could disappear very quickly but i feel
like
embrace a group did i say embrace a
group i've accidentally said enforce a
group before i feel like embrace a group
uh
everyone's gonna be watching them right
now because they've just
basically just like
thrown their power at the industry's
face but i feel positively about the
things that they are doing thus far with
these acquisitions and i very eagerly
await more information okay next up we
have
something that i am very much looking
forward to
um this is technically a reaction that
we're putting in this video today let me
just reframe this but this is the
cyberpunk 2077 phantom liberty official
teaser this is the dlc
and i believe that one keanu reeves is
returning i'm really glad to see this
being revealed i'm really excited to
watch edgerunners very soon i can't wait
to see it
obviously a very big cyberpunk fan that
didn't change for me at all and i'm
excited for more content i actually do
think i'll go back and play it on xbox
just because i actually never tried it
on console i booted it up once and i
think i just did the character creator
and that was it we might go check that
out but in any case let's watch
the make sure i'm not muted here no
cyberpunk 2077 phantom liberty official
teaser
repeat after me
i
they
do solemnly swear
i v
do solemnly switch i was like they
changed the voice actress
i shall faithfully serve the new united
states of america
that i shall faithfully serve the new
united states of america
on behalf of all americans
i thank you for your service
[Music]
it gave me goosebumps dude
interesting
and it's always extra interesting oh
it's next year that's a bubba this i
think it would be closer um
it's always extra interesting when you
get uh an international studio's take on
liberty
like she's pledging to the united states
what do you think that means to a polish
studio very cool obviously very pretty
but it's hard to say that that means
anything they
do solemnly swear
ivy
do solemnly united states
that whips doug
that looks really pretty all americans
i thank you for your service
doesn't say a lot but i think it looks
cool uh maybe that's just me i'm stoked
about it next up we have uh a story that
i also think is good news for the
industry which wow you okay get rid of
that which is xbox exec wants to show
fable now but the developer wants it to
be ready first matt booty knows that
giving the game to playground was a bit
of a head scratcher but says its work is
worth waiting for if you know me you
would know that i am a very big fable
fan
fable won and the lost chapters
specifically i didn't love two and three
as much
but i
i'm still very excited about a new fable
and i love playground i love the games
that they make
i'm excited i would love to see it every
event i'm like oh my god are we gonna
see fable but if not
that is okay
because the developers should always be
ready first and obviously this game's
not coming in the next year it would
have been in the xbox showcase for their
not e3 um that would imply that it was
coming out in the next 12 months so it's
not coming i think it's 2024 at this
point it's it's a long ways away and
that is totally fine
doesn't have to be here anytime soon the
story says head of microsoft studios
matt booty already wants to show a fable
on the xbox series x but developer
playground games has refused to do so
until it's properly ready which i would
like to note
i've almost never heard of this
happening in the aaa gaming space like
i've almost never heard of
the studio actually having a say like
this
so that's awesome speaking at pax west
2022 booty said that playground is doing
so many cool things with the next
generation fable game they ask them to
share it every time he sees it part of
my job is giving air cover to the team
he explained they don't want to show
stuff early before it's ready to go but
if there's one game where that's kind of
flipped around where every time i see
something i say we should show this it's
fable because there's a lot of cool
stuff oh i'm so excited
that being said the team has made it
very clear that i'm not going to be able
to show anything until it's ready he
gave a brief update on its development
however commenting that playground is
bringing the same craft and dedication
that they brought to forza horizon which
i
straight up think is one of the best
game series ever and that i feel like
every forza has topped the previous
forza sorry horizon specifically
they are all very very good um in a way
that when you've got you know five six
games usually there's a falter in there
somewhere i don't feel like there is in
the horizon series they're all very good
and yet have only gotten better
booty also admitted that giving fable to
a developer best known for racing games
was a bit of a head scratcher but
playground has proven that they get it i
would love to have known how that
meeting went down
like to just be able to see
what the conversation actually looked
like
when they gave it
to
playground or like what those meetings
were
pretty wild
no indication was given as to when fans
can expect to see more of the legendary
fantasy franchise but it's certainly
been a long wait so far given fable for
xbox series x was officially announced
more than two years ago in july 2020.
they probably shouldn't have done that
but i guess it was only a teaser it's
not like we've seen gameplay we just
heard that it existed
i'm talking myself back i think when you
have a new console generation people
kind of want to know what they should be
expecting um
if they're about to buy one and that was
pretty soon after release so
maybe it makes sense uh xbox has shared
that it's being developed using the
forza engine and that the game will mark
a new beginning for the fable franchise
but has remained tight-lipped otherwise
we got some screenshots here these are
probably the screens from the trailer
i mean it certainly looks different to
fable oh i can't wait
i'm so excited
so last but not least i actually can't
even get it to load which is okay
because i'm just planning to link to it
anyway um we have an early look at god
of war ragnarok's accessibility features
uh as part of the game informer
cover story because they are currently
showcasing i believe like a month worth
of go to a ragnarok content
i worked on this i'm very biased about
it obviously but i'm also just very
proud um
i can't say too much other than saying
yeah i did directly work on the
accessibility features and it was such a
pleasure to get to do so obviously very
little compared to everyone else on the
team um but i'll leave a link in the
description to where you can check this
out and you know keep an eye on some
more of game informers coverage my
internet really
really doing great today
um
it's the most accessible god of war game
so far
by a long shot
and i'm just really glad that
people who have probably previously
never played god of war before will uh
get the chance to play it for the first
time in godot ragnarok because there are
so many accessibility features over 60.
of course we did reveal that originally
um on the playstation blog on global
accessibility day but that was only some
of them
and i believe that
yeah i know i'm interested in
experiencing interruptions that uh game
informer has basically some more details
that they are allowed to share here so
if you want to check that out please do
uh a lot of them are
things that
like
are just helpful for everybody there's
this weird
kind of culture that i think is going
away where people think of the word
accessibility
as
like some negative like i don't need
that that means the game's easy it
doesn't there's just a lot of things
that make it like a fully
customizational experience something you
can customize to exactly what you want
and how you want to play a game and i
think that's way cooler and it's weird
that games are this beautiful
transformative medium that are all about
player agency and that people are
opposed to being able to customize their
way that they play exactly to what they
want
that's what's so cool about video games
they are all about how you play and this
is just giving you more choices for how
you want to play
i think it rules so i'll leave a link in
the description to where you can check
that out from uh
informer and outside of that i'm alana
thank you for watching thank you to
samsung for sponsoring the channel
and uh sorry i was away for a week it
happens there is no player watch listen
this week either um people's schedules
didn't line up but we should be back
next week and i actually have like a
bunch of videos coming this week uh
to be honest so alright bye